Nos dicen que la fórmula para convertir a
Celsius una temperatura en Fahrenheit es,
los grados Celsius o "C" es igual a 5/9 que
multiplica los grados Fahrenheit menos 32.
Reescribe la fórmula resolviendo para Fahrenheit.
Y como mencioné esta "C" son los grados Celsius,
la temperatura en grados Celsius, mientras
que la "F" es la temperatura en grados Fahrenheit...
Fahrenheit...
Así es que esta es una fórmula que nos da
"C" en términos de "F" y nos piden resolverla
para encontrar "F" en términos de "C".
Para empezar, reescribamos la fórmula,
"C" es igual a 5/9 que multiplica a "F"
menos 32 y queremos despejar "F".
Así es que lo primero que vamos a hacer es
deshacernos de este 5/9 del lado derecho de
la ecuación para que tan solo nos quede "F"
menos 32 y la manera más fácil de hacer
esto es multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por el recíproco de 5/9, hagamos eso entonces,
voy a multiplicar el lado derecho por 9/5...
voy a ponerlo aquí aunque quede un poco apretado...
y recuerda que lo que hacemos del lado derecho
hay que hacerlo también del lado izquierdo,
así es que multiplicamos el lado izquierdo
también por 9/5.
¿Qué obtenemos entonces?
Del lado izquierdo nos queda 9/5 que multiplica
a Celsius o a grados Celsius y esto es igual a...
todo esto lo hicimos para cancelar 9/5 con 5/9,
estos 9 se cancelan, estos 5 se cancelan,
el coeficiente se hace 1 y del lado derecho
nos queda grados Fahrenheit menos 32, "F"
menos 32, ya no es necesario poner el paréntesis,
pues es el único término que queda del lado derecho.
Como queremos resolver para "F", para grados
Fahrenheit, vamos a deshacernos de ese -32
del lado derecho, la manera más fácil que
conozco de hacer esto es sumar 32
a ambos lados de la ecuación...
Sumar 32 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
así es que del lado izquierdo tenemos 9/5 de grados Celsius más 32...
9/5 de grados Celsius más 32 y eso es igual
a -32 y 32 se cancelan,
por eso hicimos ese sumar 32 a ambos lados de la ecuación, así es que esto va a ser igual a "F".
Y ya hemos terminado, hemos reescrito esta fórmula que tenemos aquí arriba para grados Fahrenheit.
Aquí tenemos la expresión donde grados Fahrenheit
está en términos de grados Celsius.